yeah deca
test and HGH just call it Super Soldier
Serum cargo what how'd you get in here
don't act so surprised these are the men
who leaked the workout tape
okay in any case I'm glad you're here
Avengers because we are about to start
implementing some changes
thanks to these customer service
suggestion cards Oh president America of
the United States there's no need to
feel so proud about yourself that robot
killed literally everyone else in office
captain that's President America and
nonetheless I can now fight crime in a
more effective manner by using my words
it has also been brought to my attention
that many people believe our team to be
nationalistic jingoistic and xenophobic
yeah does that even doesn't even a thing
Zegna a princess equally fit for a
warrior to be more inclusive it is my
first action as president of the United
States to change our country's name to
United people of North America that does
not include Canada oh come on
excuse me excuse me I have the talk
conch okay that's right when you have
the talky conch it'll be your turn okay
I also realized that we have a growing
demographic problem there's a lot of
white male priviledge around here but
window-dressing the broad has no
superpowers and she can't even bench the
bar your patriarchy showing those
ridiculous domestic abuse in completely
unexplored petri Archy that's right yet
we are not allowed to hit these women as
we would a man yes I am confused you're
supposed to be you guys this is our
problem just because Black Widow sucks
at everything compared to us who
happened to be men doesn't mean that she
shouldn't be included that is what it
means that's exactly what it means see
that mindset that's perpetuating rape
culture rape culture yep that's what
Lena Dunham was talking about you mean
that wretched
goblin who fondled a little sister hey
filthy garden Hulk would smash but not
one touch hey nobody trained rape anyone
need a bone arrow in 2015 no we're
fighting robots now go away captain what
happened that's President of the United
people of Norris enough this is getting
to the point of being I'm holding the
Tok conch which means that nobody else
you know half case you show no more
hoaxes speak now okay so we can add
homophobia to the list of growing
problems here ok who cares we're the
best men for the job
let's go get it done see why did you say
men what do you think women are somehow
less capable of being great superheroes
as a general rule yes completely
unacceptable and you mean to tell me
that we can't find one african-american
to be a part of this ensemble I've been
here like literally the whole time yeah
but you're like in every movie so you
don't count what happened to Terrence
Howard anybody Terrence Howard oh I see
how it is because I ain't got no Oscar
y'all just what you looking at you big
great dumb mother oak smash yeah you try
and smash me you see what happened no no
no we do not come here Terrence Howard
oh well are guilty oppression ever end
you're such a freak like this video
subscribe by clicking my face and if you
hated it well join the club and you're
gonna hate this next video right next to
me but doesn't a part of you know what
it is